hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 46 of game
programming so today we're going to talk
about pretty much just drawing the rest
of that sprite so yesterday we took a
look at this um this whole sprite thing
growing the sprites entering the player
doing all that stuff properly aligning
at the player I guess the camera to the
player making that look really nice and
today we'll take a look at actually
drawing the rest of the place you can
see that we've got like a quarter of
player drawn and if we look at the
actual sprite there is obviously four
quarters because each section is
basically the size of one spray alright
so that's great now yesterday we
actually create it if you're going to if
you go to the sprite class which is
right over here you'll see that we
actually created four sections I guess
of the sprite we created player zero
player 1 player 2 and player 3 which
dealt with all four corners which was
great now today we're actually going to
I guess draw the four corners so it is
literally as simple as you probably
think it is over here in player where
we're entering part of the player will
guess what if we duplicate that line one
more time and draw player one which i
think is the horizontal one I think
player one nor player one's vertical no
don't buy one is horizontal like that
whoops - look they play at one and then
simply go X plus 16 and check this out
bump on BOM two sections of the freaking
King King are drawn and if we duplicate
it another two times and go play up two
and three and I think player two is y
plus sixteen and then um player three
would be both of them plus six in then
look at that
we've got King Chano here alright so
we've got this problem where obviously
we we aren't really centered and we
still do need to move sixteen across so
we can do that pretty simply all we need
to do here is just basically say in xx
let's just say equals
X like -16 and we'll do the same for Y
and then if we just simply replace that
where these and you know we should more
or less get something that looks a
little little like this and the thing is
actually centered so yeah there yeah
there you go that King channel is now
centered now we have one more problem
which I want to deal with today and that
is the the the pink stuff so pink is
usually used as a transparent color and
if we actually open up paint on that
which I'm doing right now then you
actually see that if we grab the the
eyedropper tool and we actually work out
what color that is
so here we go you can see that the color
is FF 0 0 FF that's the hexadecimal
value of the pink of that particular
shade of pink which is full full full
blue and full red as you can see so if
we without information we can actually
go into our render player method in the
screen class and we can basically tell
it not to render pixels that are off
that particular color so if we hit up
integer I can you integer called coal
and CLR stands for color right and then
we'll fill it with the color with the
pixel color so if we just come in here
and basically do that right and then set
that so that equal to color we'll do
this one step at a time so you guys get
what I'm doing so what I've done here is
I've just finding it an integer to find
a variable to take that so I've just
switched it out for a variable which has
the exact same values which give the
exact same result of course and now what
I'm going to do is before it actually
renders that I'm just going to say only
render if color is not equal to zero X
that color which is FF 0 0 FF and it
doesn't matter if these F sir lowercase
or uppercase it same effect all right so
if color does not equal pink then render
a pixel on to the screen and if we run
that you'll see that we still get pink
now why do we still get pink and the
reason we still get pink is because the
pixels sprite up pixels which is what
handles it when we actually use the
alright I think it's in sprite sheet
actually yeah if we actually use
buffered image to load sprite sheet it
doesn't only load RGB it also loads the
Alpha Channel so it's basically it
basically loads RGB a and you can see
over here that you know we are still
using RGB right if you go into Buffett
image we are also using RGB for this
right we're using RGB for this but not
for that so because of that we'll come
in compensate for that and simply say F
F so 0xff we just add an FF out front
and that'll actually as you can see get
rid of pink and create an awesome pink
churners right and that's it now a lot
of you guys the top comment actually
from yesterday's video said you know
release the sprite you know so I will
you'll find a link in the description
and you'll be able to download this
you'll be able to download you know this
this bright this King Cherno sprite and
and use it you know for rain for your
version of rain and yeah so that's cool
the other thing I wanted to mention
really quickly is like people have been
begging me to do live streams and I
don't have time to do live streams and
by live streaming I mean on the channel
engine live streams so if you guys want
to like basically if you guys want me to
like to do a live stream instead of an
episode of game programming for example
then just let me know and I'll do like
Cherno engine development like a 1 hour
or so live stream instead of um doing a
game programming episode that day so um
so yeah let me know if you guys want me
to livestream more because I'm pretty
sure you do so and tell me what day you
want me to lie to him as well like
Friday night Sunday know whatever if I'm
not busy obviously I do have a social
life so so yeah but that's a joke I
don't I'm social life um anyway the
other thing I wanted to mention quickly
was that tomorrow we will touch on
animating this little beast this little
beast of a sort of a sprite made by Andy
Wallace don't remember his name
all right see you guys later later
haters bye
you